proposal l23 as early revised is
therefore adopted
copies
the U.N Human Rights Council in Geneva
adopted a motion condemning the burning
of the Quran by an Iraqi man in Sweden
late last month
[Music]
sparked widespread condemnation and
protests across the world
among the 47 council members who voted
on Wednesday 28 voted in favor of the
resolution 12 against and seven chose to
abstain
Pakistan which brought the motion on
behalf of several countries said the
incident amounted to incitement of
religious hatred
a sentiment the Pakistani representative
says isn't shared by everyone in voting
against the resolution a message has
been sent to billions of people of Faith
across the world that their commitment
to prevent religious hatred is merely a
lip service the opposition of a few in
the room has emanated from their
unwillingness to condemn The Village the
public desecration of the Holy Quran or
any other religious book they lack
political legal and moral courage to
condemn this act and it was the minimum
that the council could have expected
from them
qatar's minister of State for
international cooperation similarly
condemned the incident
no reasonable impartial Observer can
help but
these incidents are agendas deliberately
sow hatred and Discord among Muslims and
other members of their communities
provoking two billion Muslims around the
world
many EU countries and the United States
condemned the burning of the Muslim holy
book but said the resolution threatened
freedom of speech
I believe with a little more time and
more open discussion we could have also
found a way forward together on this
resolution the U.S worked hard toward
that goal and has repeatedly condemned
the precipitating acts unfortunately our
concerns were not taken seriously
the incident has once again sparked the
debate about religious dignity and
respect and what the West considers
freedom of expression
for these protesters the answer is
simple
Mike leppel Al Jazeera